c'est au palais de la source que s'est
tenue la 5e journée départementale des
assistantes maternelles
un moment d'échangé d'informations entre
ces professionnels de la petite enfance
le public et les partenaires
c'est une journée qui consiste avant
tout à regrouper les as en maternelle
quoique et puisse donc d'abord se
connaître mais également permettre au
public de connaître un peu la profession
de 100 modèles de pouvoir répondre à
leur demande et ensuite essayer de
favoriser donc cette profession afin que
également les différents les différents
organismes qui puisse leur donner toutes
les informations nécessaires puissent
être présents c'est donc un moment des
changes
un moment de communication et un moment
également donc
pour que là tout le monde puisse avoir
les informations
la caisse endroit donc d'accord soucieux
de développer et de fédérer les savoir
faire
le département a mis en place il ya deux
ans un dispositif innovant les maisons
d'assistantes maternelles un lieu qui
regroupe plusieurs professionnels de la
petite enfance
elles sont aujourd'hui au nombre de 18
alors le gros avantage c'est qu'on ne
mélange plus les vies de famille et la
vie professionnelle pour l'assistant
maternel on arrive le matin un peu comme
au bureau on nouvelle structure on
repart le soir où on rentre à la maison
également on travaille avec les
collègues donc on a le partage des
compétences et des vécus de chacune des
expériences et sarir opus au quotidien
responsable des agréments d'assistantes
maternelles le département propose
également des aides à la formation et à
la garde des enfants par le biais du
chèque marmaille le dispositif chaque
marmaille été créés en 2012 c'est une
aide directe aux familles que la
présidente a voulu mettre en place pour
venir en aide aux familles qui
travaillent et qui peuvent bénéficier
d'une aide financière pour leurs enfants
qui sont placés ou bien en structures
d'accueil de jeunes enfants c'est-à-dire
crèche micro crèche ou auprès d'une
assistante maternelle agréée par le
département
le montant du chèque marmaille il est de
70 euros par mois maximum pour un enfant
qui placés en crèche et d'un montant
maximum de 100 euros lorsque l'enfant
est gardé auprès d'une assistante
maternelle agréée baisse est de
permettre aux parents de pouvoir de les
aider financièrement déjà dû participer
au financement puisqu'il reste un
résident elle quand même aux parents à
payer et ensuite le permettent par
exemple à des jeunes mamans d'aller
trouver du travail de pouvoir partir en
formation et je pense que c'est un
pour les aider à la station
professionnels bon je pense que c'est
une led est intéressante
le département de la réunion compte 1427
assistant maternel dont deux hommes et
offre 4142 place avec 14 mille
naissances par an et 40 mille enfants de
moins de 3 ans en 2014
la question des gardes d'enfants est un
immense défi pour la réunion